hey there guys hi from trim Ireland
beautiful trim castle by the way dating
back to 1172 a major attraction to
tourists today but I'm here in Ireland
because why wouldn't I be this is where
it all began wouldn't you know more than
2 000 years ago I want to share this
video with you because I got to visit
this spot recently uh just about 15
minutes outside of trim it's the hill of
Ward and through archaeological digging
and through the carbon dating remains
found here they determined that this is
where the very first Halloween
ceremonies would have taken place I get
more than 2 000 years ago it was called
salmon back then but they would perform
these Pagan sacrificial ceremonies on
October 31st because back then that was
the end of the calendar year and the
belief was that that's when the veil
between this world and the next was at
its thinnest and that's when the
propensity that ghosts would come on
over was at its highest and so sound
back then as the Irish spread around the
world and into the United States in the
1800s and Beyond uh Halloween today and
a lot of those those Traditions remain
uh but again it all started here more
than two thousand years ago I a lot of
people come to Ireland right around this
time of year drawn by those stories and
by that history and also by festivals
that have popped up over the last couple
of years the city of trim here and
County meath uh hosts this this is the
puka festival and there's puka she was a
mythological shapeshifter she could
bring you good luck maybe bad luck but
you wanted to behave if puka was around
and she now headlines the puka Festival
that launched in 2019 I was here for
that it was fantastic it turns the
entire town into a Halloween party for
several days and now after a pandemic uh
pause it's come make it makes its
Triumph return and dairy in Northern
Ireland Dairy Halloween which USA Today
calls the best Halloween party in the
world is that true when Fred the witch
you've been celebrating Halloween for
thousands of years it's pretty fun up
there in Dairy huh
oh absolutely Gabe I have been to many
hot spots for Halloween in my time I've
been to Salem where I received a very
warm welcome maybe too warm if you know
what I mean but Dairy has to be the best
hotspot I've ever been to they throw
Europe's biggest Halloween festival and
they lost there's lots of spooky
celebrations and little delicious oh I
mean Delightful Children all dressed up
in fancy costumes
she looks better and better every
Century but again A Taste of uh you know
what's fun uh maybe a little spooky uh
and again historic about the origins of
Halloween being embraced with these
great festivals and making Ireland the
place to spend Halloween I'd say perhaps
in 2023 you want to start making those
plans now you know we're seeing more and
more flights added out of the us as we
head toward 2023 so the time to lock
down those flights out of Vegas would be
right now uh I'm Gabe sagley in
beautiful trim Ireland happy Halloween
to you guys sending it back to you